ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier und mir wurde und in die kommentare
geschrieben dass wir acht die sind ja
immer noch hier
ihr könnt die hier bleiben
mir wurden in die kommentare geschrieben
dass ich hinten beim einem zauber tisch
doch bitte die verzauberung station bis
von daher bauen wir den zauberte schätzt
einfach mal absetzen hier noch eine
bruchstein stufe so drauf und stellen
ihnen hier hin und dann müssten wir
eigentlich schon ein bisschen geile
verzauberungen haben wir haben und nicht
weil ich nur ein bescheidener
mehr bücherregale bekommen
ich muss es tun
münchen
hier
[Musik]
dubai
ende
st
diese vorgeschichte dieses projekt sein
das ist das erste mal dass ich richtig
tiere tötet in folge 23 oder wir gerade
sind
ich kann also die vier hier vorne lasse
ich auf jeden fall leben und jetzt gehe
ich mal ganz kurz rein und sammle den
ganzen kreis hier auf der hier getoppt
wurde
haha es tut mir leid leute ich werde
euch auch irgendwann demnächst frei
lassen und dann eine tier insel bauen
falls sie da irgendwelche vorschläge
habt schreibt mir gerne und in die
kommentare
schlaff herunter
[Musik]
alles gut unser breakdance schwein geht
auf jeden fall ordentlich ab der lernt
in jeder folge neue skill moves ich
werde jetzt ganz kurz mal hier fordern
das zuckerrohr abfällen denn das
benötigen wir immer noch für unsere
bücher herunter
[Musik]
den sieg in den später und leute
freiwillig hier ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr ich laufe einfach
lange ich habe es euch gerade bringen
lassen leute schreiben
es gibt reddot post und retz und ging
welche diskussionen instagram gruppen ob
ich diese welt medien wie entschieden
habe und dass ich hier irgendwie
hinsetzen und keine ahnung was denkt ihr
denn dass ich das auch spaß mache hier
so kipper hinsetzen
ich tue alles gut wir vorne sieht alles
wieder vernünftig aus was sich auch noch
ganz kurz machen wollte war via wir
haben uns ja vorne die kühe gerade
getötet degas dieses schaffner alles gut
wir wollten bzw
ich wollte hier vorne eben in die truhe
das restliche höheren verstand was ich
gerade durch die tür bekommen habe durch
meinen durch meinen tötungsvorgang
dahinter
ich möchte allerdings
ich bleibe euch jetzt mal kurze time lab
sein weil dieser part der folge ziemlich
langweilig war also ich hab nur das
leder zum bücherregal gemacht und meine
ganzen sachen verzaubert und jetzt
machen wir eine entdeckerreise in eine
richtung in die wir noch nie gefahren
sind hier vorne ist meine insel auf der
ich wohne und wir wollen jetzt einfach
mal in diese richtung hier ich habe zwei
hier vorne die insel immer so ein
bisschen genutzt um bäume zu fällen aber
auch nachzupflanzen also wir sehen ja
der baumbestand hier ist wirklich riesig
allerdings bin ich noch nicht nach vorne
gefahren seid mal vor da kommt jetzt
einfach gar nichts sondern einfach so
ein abgrund weil die erde ist eine
scheibe wie jeder weiß doch dann wenige
sekunden später ich bin wirklich nicht
weit gefahren nämlich läge er diese eben
[Musik]
ich sitze sei keine ahnung ich bin 20
sekunden gefahren oder irgendwie so aber
es ist es ist einfach ein studium direkt
bei uns nebenan
was geht hier ab
[Applaus]
das erste was wir hier in den schnee die
um natürlich machen ist erstmal das
fichtenholz mitnehmen das ist nämlich so
geil ich bin damit kann man so viel
schönere sachen wir uns mit unserem
komischen eichenholz das ist hier vorne
ist kann man war richtig geil darüber
schlimmer so ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
ich gehe erst mal hier hinten kurz zum
zucker ort nehmen das mit das ist ja
immer wichtig zum verzaubern für bücher
und so weiter und so fort hier vorne
haben wir so ein bisschen weiter über
den fluss lang
was ist das da hinten das ist nicht
gedacht hat er wird schäfchen stehen die
vorne ist eine krasse höhle aber wie
bereits gesagt sind wir nicht wegen der
höhlen hier sondern wir wollen einfach
so ein bisschen erkunden sondern
bisschen rumlaufen und es ist jetzt zwar
blöd dass ich kein bett mitgenommen aber
wir werden das schon überleben erst was
ich gerade gesagt habe es ist mitten in
der nacht und ich bin mitten in einem
lichten wald und die skelette hier vorne
attackieren mich die ganze zeit ich habe
keine feinde mehr ich hab keine pfeile
mehr sagt aber ich kriege ich auf jeden
fall noch ich nehme hier vorne den kram
smid ich hab hier wird auch einer stehen
[Musik]
ich dachte mir geil alter schöne
entdeckungsreise ich habe ja völlig
vergessen dass es auch nachts wird jetzt
bin ich hier in irgendeinem fichtenwald
ich höre was ist hier das ist nichts da
kommt zombie an alter was ist den ich
jetzt hier los
ich dachte das wird eine richtig
entspannt entdeckungstour
ich habe gar nicht damit gerechnet dass
sie auch monster's ball und das ist
nacht wirklich toll dass auch noch nie
und ich bin auch noch mitten im wald wo
ich mich überhaupt nicht auskenne und es
ist halt winter das ist ja auch noch mal
ein bisschen furcht einflößender
gefordert ist sehe ich habe mich
wirklich gerade dorf gefunden
wir sind runde hätte ich richtig mit mit
einem knochen hin
so bleibt man hier sitzen neben ich muss
mal ganz kurz ihnen wohl weihnachten
gehen kommen hier raus ich gehe mal hier
rein was war ich schon wieder los leute
ich geh jetzt trotzdem noch mal durch
das komplette dorf durch und schaue ob
hier irgendwelche sachen sind die es
sich lohnt wird zunehmen hier vorne sind
nur kessel die brauche ich jetzt
eigentlich nicht erst mal
wir haben hier vorne doch ein häuschen
da war ich aber glaube ich gerade schon
drin oder ja genau dadurch anrufer
abgesetzt hier hinten am ende des weges
ist auch noch ein häuschen hier ist
allerdings nichts drin und bettchen das
nehme ich mir allerdings mal mit damit
wir uns vielleicht auf der
erkundungstour noch mal hinlegen können
nachher also da vorne ist das dörfchen
gewesen und die laufen jetzt einfach mal
in diese richtung denn wir kamen ja aus
der richtung haben jetzt ein kleines
dreieck was wir so ein bisschen ablaufen
ich habe keine ahnung was das hier sieht
irgendwie so ein bisschen aus wie das
new world trade center ich finde es
wirklich so geisteskrank heftig was aus
minecraft geworden ist ich weiß noch als
ich damals angefangen habt mit minecraft
da war es noch
[Musik]
ich habe keine ahnung was ich da vorne
gerade entdeckt habe und es war auch
nicht so aus als ob die leute die davor
standen mit ihren komischen bögen mich
für so lieblich gehalten haben er kommt
schon an
das sieht nicht so dass ich nicht so
freundlich aus ich das in erster linie
okay er geraten kann
er greift jetzt muss ich so attackieren
um ein gott je mehr richtig schaden ok
vier mal schlagen mit einem diamant
schwert ich werde jetzt einmal an den
ball
du wartest hier aber wir machen wir gab
dem schaden weil meine diamanten so
stark dass sie etwas suchen die sich
diese rüstung verzögert hatte und wenn
wir so viele von denen warten
oh mein gott es kommt immer näher dann
wird das aber wahrscheinlich ziemlich
krass was wir da oben kriegen oder
diakonisches banana auf dem kopf
keine ahnung was bei ihm haben
freiwillige spex ziel habe ich jetzt
hier noch erhalten ich setze jetzt
einfach mal fackeln hin weil es
mittlerweile schon nacht ist das werden
einfach nicht weniger es hat keine
ahnung wie viel ich von den töten muss
oder ob die wirklich immer wieder spott
ist einfach nicht auch gucken was uns
erwartet nicht dass da noch mehr von
diesen leuten sind oder irgendwelche
fallen oder so aber man muss sich
anscheinend gibt es oben hochkämpfen
hier ist noch nichts keine kisten nichts
gar
hier auch nicht und hier oben haben eine
kiste und darin
holz weizen ein bisschen leise und zwei
erfahrungsfeld klett sprachen lernen
von daher werde ich jetzt einfach mal
balu von hier vorne mitnehmen der sitzt
hier vorne genau zack und dann laufen
wir es einfach mal in richtung heimat
[Musik]
ich dachte ich wäre in dem dorf was ich
gerade schon gefunden haben bleibt mal
kurz aber oben steht überfall und das
doch sie doch mit ich hab keine ahnung
was wir hier wieder ein geraten sind die
leiste oben genau jetzt voll und ich
habe keinen plan was hier abgeht da
kommt mein gott da kommen diese komische
leute mit den grünen da was machen
der check zu auf jeden fall bisher noch
nicht so richtig die kommen
mit einem schild ja die gibt es nur die
leute auf 7 deutlich arbeitet die nicht
überfallen sagt jo du bist du gefragt
gefordert wird von den bildern von dem
er irgendwie also die leiste oben fühlt
sich wie da ist genug da kommt schon
wieder mehr leute die uns irgendwie
angreifen wollen liga ich habe keinen
plan was hier abgeht hier vorne auf die
vorderachse an das geht denn jetzt ab
hier ist der bar boni damit seinem
komischen ball am kopf der ist aber auch
tod der die leitung oben jedoch immer
wieder voller ich weiß nicht ob die
immer mehr leute kommen die uns
überfallen wollen vor allem um stick als
was man dort vom helfe ich den idioten
überhaupt
was
ein wildschwein
was geht denn jetzt ab
denn neun stellen
die karten
[Musik]
also
ich habe keinen plan was hier abgeht
[Musik]
aber ebenso ein schwein
der typ da und hat wieder seine dumme
antwort das weiß ich noch nicht richtig
unter
und er geht zum dorf
handy gab es geht den sätzen
ich mache jetzt einfach witzig sie auch
da mld reisen golem nimmt auf jeden fall
gerade mit diesem komischen tier hier
ich kämpfe auch einfach mal mit er ist
auf jeden fall tot überfall steht da
oben immer noch ich werde den einst und
jetzt einfach mal mit eisen zusammen ich
habe keine ahnung ob der mir das danken
wird weil es ja eigentlich gar nicht
mein dorf ist ihr überfall bald ein
relikt sich wieder weiter auf ich hab
was geht denn hier ab der ball geht sie
gut da freut mich was hat denn jetzt ab
wie viele es intern ihr alter und fand
ja noch gibt sachen über verlegt sich da
oben wieder aufdecken was sind wir
reingeraten ich wollte entdeckungs folge
machten keine action folge schon wieder
alter was beschwören die da jemand der
junge passiert er jetzt ab was geht denn
jetzt endlich darf nicht sterben ich
habe so viele leben ich nun so lange
nicht gestorben diesem projekt und jetzt
kommen die stadt mit der 84
ich wollte eine ganz normale
entdeckungsfreude und jetzt ist es eine
komplette action folge was ist los was
ist so schrecklich bitte in die
kommentare was ich hier rein geraten bin
ich wollte doch nur dass dort besetzen
wir jetzt wird zwei wochen macht das
heißt es kommen noch zombies und monster
generell gut schnitt da hinten
hier ist wieder dieser um ein kräftiger
was ist denn hier los man da ist wieder
die cool
zugleich muss jetzt so sieht ist nicht
wahr ich muss ihnen bei hohen und hier
[Musik]
verfolgen mich die ganze zeit tief ist
immer noch hinter mir
das kann nicht wahr sein dasein skelette
keeper der typ ist immer noch hinter mir
dieser andere auch gesagt ich muss bahr
nun da lassen wir müssen bei einer
anderen folge holen
es kann und ich war denn ich muss hier
weg ich musste ganz schnell weg hier ist
immer noch interniert die spinne
sortiere kaiser kommt ja auch ins wasser
er kommt nicht ins wasser oder du
schaffst das
wir sind wieder zu hause meine lieben
freunde ich habe mich so gefreut den
hund hiermit hin zu bringen und mit dem
einen draufzusetzen das schwein hat sich
immer noch reingepackt allerdings ist
das leider nichts geworden wir müssen
auf jeden fall in einer der nächsten
folgen noch mal drüber hinten zu dem
schnee dorf zu dem überfall keine ahnung
was da genau passiert ist wir haben auf
jeden fall einige neue sachen mitbringen
mitgenommen und ich dachte auch wir
könnten den überfall bewältigen
allerdings hat es nicht so ganz geklappt
weil es immer mehr wurde wir sind
allerdings wieder zu hause angekommen
unserer kleinen süßen welt hier vorne es
ist wirklich richtig schön wieder hier
zu sein das war zwar geil hinten auf der
erkundungstour und wir können noch mal
ganz kurz gucken ob unsere spiele
geschlüpft sind da ist nichts
vorangegangen natürlich nicht allerdings
freut man sich dann ja doch irgendwie
immer wieder wenn man zu hause ist das
ist ein bisschen so wie urlaub machen es
ist schön irgendwie in spanien italien
keine ahnung wo wenn das wetter guided
und wenn man das schön unterwegs ist
aber zuhause ist immer noch am schönsten
und mit den worten möchte ich dir
heutigen episode minecraft mit
jugendbanden meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat alles gern einen
daumen hoch unter mir da abonniert neuen
kanal wenn ihr die erste folge minecraft
mit luca nicht verpassen wollte kommt
übermorgen am dienstag um 20 uhr online
und bitte schreibt ort in die kommentare
was ich hier machen sollen mit diesem
über bald chelsea
[Musik]